un autre report une autre déception
selon siby si le gouvernement fédéral
s'apprête à prolonger la fermeture
terrestre entre le canada et les états
unis au moins jusqu'à la fin octobre je
serai pas jouer sa conjointe ne savent
plus ce qu'ils vont faire
en vain jusqu'à fin novembre où les
français finalement repasser après ceux
d'autres sont déterminées à partir
brigitte comtois vie dans son véhicule
récréatif à l'année on avait prévu le
coup 9 un plan plan b puis là-bas on est
sur notre plan b
on a réservé à vancouver exaspéré
d'attendre l'ouverture de la frontière
terrestre alors que la frontière
aérienne
elle est ouverte plusieurs snowbirds
font appel à des transporteurs de
véhicules récréatifs et téléphonie avec
peu de sommeil surtout depuis qu'il à
chaque fois qu'une annonce que les
douanes sont fermés on reçoit entre 50
et 100 appels par jour transport kmc se
spécialise dans le transport commercial
il est autorisé à passer la frontière
sans problème les snowbirds doivent
cependant répondre à certains critères
il faut que la personne est une preuve
de résidence aux états unis ça prend une
preuve du billet d'avion acheté 100
prend les formulaires des douanes dumas
rappelé pour une somme oscillant entre
3500 et 5000 dollars
une bénédiction pour maryse legendre qui
angoissé à l'idée de demeurer au québec
cet hiver là ça a été là la solution la
solution la snow board met en garde les
autres voyageurs contre la surenchère
des transporteurs j'ai eu des tarifs qui
pouvaient tripler quadrupler pour le
même trajet
michel silvestri prépare sa caravane
pour l'hiver pour lui et sa femme
pas question de traverser la frontière
chez chute avec toute l'incertitude
cet ouvrage s'est pas ouvert on a décidé
de rester au québec selon c'est à québec
la moitié des snowbirds prévoit rester
au canada cet hiver en raison de lakovic
même si de plus en plus de compagnies
d'assurances accepte de protéger leurs
clients contre le coronavirus ya
certains assureurs qui sortent des
avenants donc sur un certain montant
supplémentaire à dos bon si il y en a
d'autres qui l'ont mis dans leur police
de balles ce qui en a d'autres qui font
une tarification spéciale mais il n'ya
pas que la maladie qui inquiète michel
et nicole la cover de les élections les
émeutes de 6e ne faut pas attention que
l'aco but pour réseaux c'est comme
prendre une grippe y avait un look mais
la beauce et rouge beaucoup là aussi le
stepper on vous le dit long sur le cash
repos nos pieds les mesures 4 ohms
prince est pas tout à fait les mesures
que monsieur legault prend non plus ça
aussi c'est à y penser
une gestion de la pandémie au sud de la
frontière qui pourrait freiner plusieurs
snowbirds ici marie josée paquet comme
radio canada montréal